depuis son ouverture le 29 avril 2020 au
coeur du premier confinement le gave et
deux autres s'ils peinent à trouver des
clients comme bon nombre de restaurants
le recours au télétravail demandé par le
gouvernement est un frein pour le
secteur - dette de l'état de clients
aussi et un recours à la livraison
parfois coûteux une recette qui a du mal
à passer on va quand même remercier
l'état de nous avoir bien l'aider
l'année dernière mais bon voilà là c'est
vrai que du coup on nous met un peu des
bâtons dans les roues actuellement avec
le télétravail mais on nous parle pas de
ce qu'on va pouvoir récupérer derrière
parce que là au final on n'a pas de
fermeture donc on va pas avoir d' aide
mais par contre on nous retire en gros
nos clients l'autre jour on a fait 50
couverts toute la semaine on était à 25
donc moi ce jour là j'avais dit à mon
employé on y va mollo parce que en prépa
sinon on va voir de la perte donc ce
jour là on se dit bon au niveau
tranquille et au final on a cinquante
couverts qui arrive donc c'était la
course on a eu un manque on a perdu des
clients qu'on n'a pas pu honorer tous le
télétravail mais aussi le pass
sanitaires autant de mesures qui pousse
les consommateurs à revoir leurs
habitudes pour certains restaurateurs
les pertes atteignent plus de la moitié
du chiffre d'affaires on constate depuis
ie août depuis la mise la mise en place
du pass sanitaire une baisse de nos de
nos chiffres d'affaires qui est
progressive depuis ou tuer et qui arrive
à un point de moins 50 moins 60% pour
pour janvier et vous pourrez constater
denrées en moi ce qu'ils soient
installés comme commerçant dans le
quartier depuis 89 j'ai jamais connu une
ville déserte comme ça où les
restaurants sont vides le mythique et
banques ont
ont fermé les robinets pour la plupart
pour pour pour notre type de profession
et le
mécanisme va prendre peut-être un peu de
temps mais en 2022 il y aura de la casse
face à cette situation le premier
ministre jean castex annoncé mardi de
nouvelles mesures pour le secteur l'aide
au paiement des cotisations salariales
et l'exonération des charges patronales
sous certaines conditions un retour
progressif à la politique du quoi qu'il
en coûte